a mother-daughter duo in florida they
face up to 16 years in prison
after allegedly cheating their way to
homecoming royalty
officials announced this week that
18-year-old emily grover will be tried
as an adult she was arrested in march
before her latest birthday after
authorities say she rigged her school's
homecoming queen
contest so she would win her mom laura
carroll
is an assistant principal in the same
school district she was
also arrested and suspended from her job
the pair
are accused of illegally accessing the
district's internal computer system
to cast hundreds of fake votes from
private student accounts they've pled
they've pleaded not guilty to multiple
felony charges
we've reached out to both women we
haven't heard back
i wouldn't respond to you either you
reached out to me i mean this is
uh you know is this a crime crime that's
a good question
246 votes they cast illegally right
and they went to a lot of trouble system
to look up student accounts to look up
grades
there's a conspiracy element i have i
don't have a lot of sympathy for the mom
i do for the child who was underage when
this all happened
i'm sure the mom was like honey uh
you're you're great you're wonderful and
then tried to organize this thing to
probably help her daughter
exactly it is broader than this in the
sense that that one of the student
students testified that that this girl
emily grover logged into her mom's
school account
in order to access grades and test
scores that's right
which is which is your mom is in a
position of authority
but this sounds like a reese witherspoon
movie it doesn't sound like a federal
election
great films you know i you know i
teach your children well csny thank you
that's the way i feel about that
okay stills nash oh okay i'm like
your children well i